[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you so much to my 15 280 students
for nominating me for this teaching with
digital technology award
we are obviously living at a very
important time for higher education
and we have collectively the opportunity
to reinvent how we're delivering that
type of content
and i'm very much looking forward to
understanding how collectively we we
find new ways of delivering
um technology called content to uh
to our students to and to empower them
to use them in practice but also
to enhance their educational experience
the materials that we explore and the
sense of community that we foster
provides us with the space and
opportunity
to showcase our care for one another and
so
once we had to face the tragedy of kobe
19
the means to express our care and our
joy for being together change
the foundation remains the same
my main approach to teaching is really
over sharing
in the interest of building community i
think that there can be no
real learning without trust and there
can be no trust without
sharing our own vulnerabilities and it
just so happened that the week of the
campus closure
we were discussing the importance of
connectedness to
place for human well-being so i
immediately asked the students to think
about
what it feels like when the place that
you feel most connected to
is rested from you could this help us
empathize
with the plight of displaced peoples in
the world
for instance i wanted the students to be
anthropologists
studying this strange new reality
and for that spirit of curiosity
to empower them and to give them
strength
the different life circumstances out of
which we make meaning
but we often call our backgrounds the
fitting metaphor perhaps for the zoom
era
has now come ever to the foreground
remote teaching was a heartbreak though
it had its unexpected boons
as speaking with students fixed in
equally sized video boxes made our
discussions more democratic
though also made clear because of the
absence of students unable reliably to
connect
how far we have to go in building this
commons
the fact highlighting the real danger in
which u.s and world democracy now find
themselves
a peril that must see us confront racial
injustice digital division
public health catastrophe and the rise
of unreason
we threw away all or most of our plans
in the interest of getting the best
learning experience to our students when
we first
got word that this semester was going to
be online
one of the thoughts that went through my
head was
how is a two inch high
two dimensional version of me possibly
going to compete with
all of the other things that
are on students computer screens the
first time
i set up a graph i actually walked off
screen
and then did a little computer trickery
and it looked like i walked
inside of the graph inside of my slide
luckily mit has great resources in
digital learning
such as the videotaping rooms and the
mitx system
when the class was moved online i
decided to use
onenote as my virtual blackboard it's
quite easy to use
writing and drawing on it feel really
smooth cat soup is
free and open source software it's
freely available online
and over the past several semesters
we've seen a
pretty steady increase in the number of
subjects using it at mit
and you know sometimes these are
subjects that are very different from
the ones that i teach
and so it's been extra neat to see
the the things that they're doing with
the software and the ways that they're
extending it as well as reproducing all
of the
key features of in-person lectures and
office hours as much as possible
the other guiding principle of
flexibility meant making the course
content as accessible as possible in as
many formats as possible
this is a very hands-on class we set the
foundation by going through the
calculations
that an astronomer will make in order to
determine what exposure time
they should use when at the telescope
the students were able to do this for
the target of their choice
and then submit this as a request to the
elliott 24-inch telescope at wallace
observatory
although they weren't there for the
actual experiments
by watching the videos and then talking
with me and listening to my
presentations in the
lab times and then meeting with us
individually about their spectra
they were able to sort of wrap this up
and talk about their peptide to each
other and us
a one-on-one zoom conference is very
productive
and has the advantage that the student
can re record the session
so that if they we talk and say
something and they forget what we said
they can go back and look at it again
which is not what happens in person when
they're meeting with us in the lab
so i have to admit that when i got the
email about winning a digital
technology teaching award i thought it
was a joke
or a scam because
i am famously clueless with technology i
have to get my students to set it up if
i need a
class e list or a google doc
or what have you we also use technology
to travel
virtually when we couldn't do it in real
life
for example by walking city streets and
google view mode
visiting museum rooms browsing our
restaurant menus
for some sections of the course i
flipped the classroom what this means is
that i
recorded lectures narrated some slides
and sent those out in advance
and then during the synchronous remote
class time period on zoom
we use that time to have more
discussions
many cases work out problems we also
discuss the real-time
changes that were happening in the u.s
tax code in response to the pandemic
virtual class discussions just tend to
stall at unexpected moments
and when that happened what helped for
me was to use breakout rooms
learning objectives can be achieved in
many different ways you know we might be
used to
achieving a learning objective in a
particular way that's been done for many
years
i think the transition to online
teaching has made us take a step back
and acknowledge that perhaps there are
multiple ways to get at that
objective i designed a variety of games
anywhere from bingo to battleship
some ideas work better than others but
students embrace these experiments with
incredible flexibility and good humor
i've been asked what did we do to create
appealing and thought-provoking lectures
here's some tips one lectures
are stories two design
for the media we're used to seeing
videos with cuts every 2.5 seconds
keep it moving and three it's okay to
have fun
lots of the activities in my classes are
role play simulations or scenarios
that put students in specific
contexts that mimic real world or
professional
practice contexts ask them to use what
they've been reading and talking about
and then give each other feedback and
then we often video
what they're doing so they can see
how they're presenting themselves to
other people
in other people's eyes i really
appreciated and enjoyed
the discussions via zoom the students
were really
willing to engage and ask questions and
i felt
we could create not quite but almost
a classroom atmosphere we've learned in
this digital teaching environment
to bring socratic dialogue which allows
students
to be the agents who educate each other
and us the instructors it's been a very
powerful way of teaching students
how to discover for themselves i can't
think enough for this
i'll never forget our class so never
forget the spring of 2020
and i look forward to see you all on
campus again
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
you